I will start with facts which I believe
are gerine to the the question as it's
formulated uh and just sites and
statistics I know that statistics can
always be made to prove anything but in
this case I give you my word that they
are objectively selected and are not
misleading in the first 16 years of this
new century the GDP per capita of the
United States has grown by
1% and if it had grown in this period at
the rate that it did in the last 20
years of the 20th century the people the
families and individuals of the United
States would be on average 20% wealthier
than they
are in this period 15 million people
have fallen out of the workforce the
percentage of Americans above the age of
20 who work has declined by nearly
fivefold % and the number of hours
worked any kind of legitimate work in
the United States in that period has
declined by the shocking total of
12%
these these are very dangerous figures
and a very dangerous
Trend and the impact of this is is very
burdensome to the country and it's very
worrisome to the country and you must
remember that the ethos of the United
States is one of such optimism and such
ambition that it is not a country
accustomed to the concept of decline at
any time and it has never had a period
of absolute or comparative decline such
as it has had in the last 15 to 20 years
and it it very much concerns the whole
country but coming up to the election it
must be said this was not mentioned by
the established elements of either party
it was very little mentioned in the
media and and
it was really only seized upon by
outlier candidates to some degree
Senator
Sanders who is uh a democratic quasi
Marxist and on the other side on the
Republican right Senator Cruz now if you
people are startled by Donald Trump you
will really be shocked if you get a good
look at Senator Cruz he's pitched his
whole campaign to the corn covers and
the wool hats and the people with
automatic weapons in the rear windows of
their pickup trucks and and he uh as far
as I can see would hand over the
Pentagon to the National Rifle
Association and he declared in
Indianapolis last spring that God told
him to run for
president and in this last election year
in policy terms Trump was a moderate he
was he is in favor of universal healthc
care it's obviously going to be with
some difficulty that he gets there but
he's in favor of it at least as a
concept and he is in favor of lower
taxes for lower income people and higher
taxes for higher wealth people and in
policy terms he's a very reasonable
person the the fact that Mrs Clinton
referred to half of Trump's supporters
as
deplorable was extremely unwise given
that she was after all running for the
highest office in the country and these
people are worried and
what occurred was an assault by Trump
upon the entire political establishment
he ran against all factions of both
parties he ran against practically all
the media almost all of audible and
visible Academia he ran against the
lobbyists the polling organizations the
bureaucracy Wall Street and quite
explicitly uh that
infestation of useful to his enemies
idiots in Hollywood he ran against all
of them and he
won uh and he has one with a program
that is quite radical he has a tax plan
which I understand he tends to reveal at
the end of this week uh which will
include
taxes sharply reduced for all
corporations sharply reduced for lower
income groups a tax incentives to start
a DE decades late renovation of national
infrastructure incentivizing $2 trillion
of retained profit overseas to return to
the US uh and and he has already
dismantled the nonsense of global
warming and he has a he has already
shown that he will um give the country
as has been mentioned a foreign policy
that is neither the trigger happy
belligerency of George W or the
panglossian Fant y of Obama telling
America's enemies and allies to change
roles in places thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much indeed Conrad
black now the first voice against the
motion kakan is a Muslim American lawyer
whose son was killed in action in Iraq
at the 2016 US Democratic party
convention he denounced Trump's call for
a ban on migrants from some Muslim
countries and questioned his
understanding of the US Constitution
kakan please make your way to the
Elon good evening America is discovering
the true nature of this
president and the motion
is Trump is making America great again
and I stand before you against the
motion here are the facts you remember
the very loudly
pronounced bigoted statement by
candidate Trump
was I will build the wall and Mexico
will pay for the
wall well friends we all know Mexico is
not paying for the
wall and the wall is not being built the
reason is that to build the wall you
need
funding and Congress has loudly
announced that they will not allocate
any funding for the building of the wall
so we are
waiting remember the second promise and
loudest promise was we will repeal and
replace Affordable Care Act in United
States he promised that during the
election campaign and then he
tried and you saw 3 weeks ago How It Was
Defeated when it went to the Congress
his party is the majority party in the
Congress yet that proposal Was
Defeated
third jobs I will create thousands of
jobs in United States and where are the
jobs
we don't see them even in the near
future we don't see them so that is the
job
promise I am a Muslim American I am a
patriotic Muslim
American I consider myself responsible
for the Safety and Security of the
United
States we heard Muslim ban number one
and Muslim ban number
two you all know where the ban
is rule of law has
prevailed the fifth and much talked
about accomplishment is the appointment
of Judge Gorsuch to Supreme
Court he's going to make America great
again no he's
not Senate rule were
changed instead of 60 votes were Chang
change to simple
majority that is the only accomplishment
that you know that he had been able to
do
remember within 100 days within 100
days his National Security
advisor agent of foreign
governments was disgracefully walked out
of White House was asked to resign
keep these issues that I mentioned to
you is this the way to
govern one of the
most enviable
democracy in the
world I oppose this motion you heard my
brief
statements and my story that continues
my journey that continues is in
opposition
of Donald
Trump in support of democracy Democratic
Values Safety and Security of my country
Safety and Security of
Europe Safety and Security of
mankind thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much
thank you kazir Khan now our second
speaker for the motion is Aaron Banks
he's a former major donor to ukip the UK
independence party and co-founder of
leave.eu he recently quit ukip to set up
a new populist political force called
the Patriotic Alliance whose aim is to
bring Trump style politics to the UK
he's also launched the
anti-establishment news website West
Monster which is modeled on the American
websites Breitbart and The Drudge Report
Aaron please make your way to the Elon
thank
[Music]
you good evening um I just want to
tackle the the last point that the last
speaker made as a businessman to achieve
anything in a 100 days is uh pretty much
impossible let alone make America great
so I think Donald Trump has set out to
actually do the things he said he was
going to be elected Ed to do the fact
that the
establishment both in the Republican
party and elsewhere have tried to stop
him is not an indictment of his
presidency after 100 days what I wanted
to do was reel back the clock a little
bit and look about the reason Donald
Trump was elected in the first place
globalization has caused massive
dislocations within the world we've seen
huge amounts of money transfer from the
poor to the rich in fact just to I I I I
left Mayfair in the morning we went down
to Clanton and visited what is the
poorest part of England in a place
called jaywick this overlooked it's uh
it's a shambolic place the contrast
between Mayfair and that area that was
you know utterly just hollowed out to be
frank and it takes us where we we joined
the Trump story in Mississippi where we
were asked to go down or Niger was asked
to go down and speak in Jackson
Mississippi and 20, ,000 people came out
to listen to Donald Trump and to listen
to farage and there were another 20,000
queed down the road and the reason was
that in
essence they were disappointed with the
political class and the fact I think
Conrad mentioned all the economic stance
but the only one you need to know is a a
salary of a normal American a flatline
for over eight years you know the the
communities were HED out and so joh
Donald Trump was a response a kind of
almost anti-political response now I
would agree with some of the comments of
the previous speaker he's a deeply
flawed candidate a deeply flawed
president but what he represents is a
catalyst and I don't think that Donald
Trump will make America great again I
think the people of America will and
when we look at the major policies which
you know is to bring back jobs into
America to look at how you could uh
change the tax system to actually bring
companies back in there's something like
$2
trillion parked offshore out of America
because the tax system of America means
that corporation tax there is 38% the
highest in the the Western world and I
think he's got a whole range of policies
that will be very beneficial but I think
we have to see it in the context the
same as brexit why did brexit happen
people in London didn't see it coming
because they didn't go out and look if
you actually look at what's happened to
communities in our country they've been
hollowed out and actually it was a
reaction from the poorest in our society
that thought that the politicians and
the the the sort of
Corporations it just wasn't in in in
their benefit and I think that's very
much where Donald Trump has come in I
think you know I I watch the French
election macron's going to win I can
tell you if the entire British
establishment line up and say pick that
guy and and not Marie Le Pen in the same
way that everybody lined up against
Trump there's going to be big trouble
and that and don't rule it out so I
think from my perspective it's not a
question of whether Donald Trump will
make America great again it's whether he
will free up Americans to once again
make America great again that's my
that's my key point I had to
make
I